vegeta has been coming for kakarot for
decades now in dragon ball and in the
post-credit scene of the new dragon ball
super movie the unthinkable finally
happened warning spoilers ahead for
dragon ball super
yourself and superhero that power
the 21st feature installment in the
dragon ball series dominated the us box
office after its first weekend in
theaters taking the number one position
with a 20 million dollar opening twice
the take of its predecessor dragon ball
super broly of course dragon ball super
superhero hasn't just made an impressive
financial impact much like its
predecessor the new film has received
overwhelmingly positive reviews from
critics and seems to be doing even
better among casual viewers the film's
story which revolves around piccolo and
gohan's combined efforts to take down a
dangerous reformed version of the red
ribbon army allows dragon ball super
superhero the chance to deliver plenty
of memorable scenes as well not only
does dragon ball super superhero feature
more than its fair share of instantly
iconic piccolo and gohan moments but the
film also finds some time to turn its
attention to some of the dragon ball
franchise's other fan favorite
characters that's especially true in the
film's noteworthy post-credits scene
which revolves around a twist that some
dragon ball fans may think has been a
long time coming before dragon ball
super superhero becomes fully engrossed
in piccolo and gohan's fight against the
red ribbon army it takes a moment to
briefly check in with vegeta and goku at
the start of the film the two dragon
ball fighters are on beerus planet and
in the midst of training once that has
been established dragon ball super
superhero becomes largely preoccupied
with piccolo gohan and the pair's
various red ribbon army combatants most
of the movie is focused on their fight
giving dragon balls less powerful
players a chance to shine on the silver
screen however before dragon ball super
superhero cuts to black for the last
time the film does take a moment to
bring things full circle and check back
in with goku and vegeta who have
apparently spent the entire movie in a
fight of their own at the very end
dragon ball super superhero delivers a
genuinely surprising moment one that
fans of the franchise may have
previously thought they'd never actually
get to see on screen when the film's
post-credits scene begins both goku and
vegeta are exhausted from their
off-screen fight as their battle winds
down vegeta slowly throws one final weak
tiny punch that proves to be enough to
force goku to admit defeat toppling him
to the ground vegeta obviously takes a
moment to truly cherish his victory
before collapsing to the ground himself
exhausted finally after all these years
he's technically defeated kakarot
vegeta's victory over goku is an
undeniably major dragon ball moment
however it should be noted that vegeta
gets his win under very specific
circumstances for starters his and
goku's fight in the film isn't a to the
death battle but a sparring match with
no energy blasts or transformational
powers being used that means that the
two combatants are essentially forced to
rely solely on their martial arts skills
and normal stamina levels all of which
is to say that while vegeta's win will
likely still be celebrated by fans of
the character dragon ball super
superhero does go out of its way to make
it clear that his fight with goku isn't
exactly an all-out brawl earlier in the
movie vegeta also takes the time to
meditate before the battle noting his
belief that doing so will give him an
advantage the post-credit scene proves
him right giving longtime fans of the
saiyan prince the victory they've always
wanted at long last
[Music]